welcome to this video playing Nick
healed Nikhil from the u.s. never layton
before is this a new handle yo pretty
pretty new handle the terrassa maybe go
for this many lines in the talaash
available 92 is not putting that must
not love that much pressure on black so
you have quite them quite a range of
options this is not played very often I
think you to Queen t5 let's go for that
and interesting so is it rigged it
cannot take here this should be four or
what exactly this so great I'm time to
attempt it let's let's let's check what
happens Queen g5 and they have c5
attacked
the problem is with with this Jeep on
it's not that the pawn is gone but where
do you put your king it's not so so
self-evident how you how you get a quick
development going here yeah you're black
it's just material of really yeah where
to put it probably here right so that i
can use this this weekend diagonal
Bishop d7 to c6 for example would be a
would be interesting okay let's go for
that right least introduce this idea to
the position he will probably do
something against it hmm okay not really
Bishop c6 that's what 94 yeah probably
nite b to d 4 then i have e 5 actually
takes on 696 yeah okay let's not fall
too far behind on the clock that's them
that's the main scenario how this game
still can be lost spending too much time
in a good position and then lose on time
so I'm still having this annoying
pressure on the on the knight on f3 and
I was thinking that maybe Queenie to us
now the way to go try to yam trying to
prepare long castles but I was I'm quick
enough with the aid to prevent that
okay so we will not cancel anymore
should I just Castle myself now I guess
so what an interesting way to play it
can be 94 at some point but first maybe
just check take care and gain this
temple yeah there's also 95 by the way
it's not a bad bad idea taking the the
bishop
this is also preparing bishop f6 which
helps to secure g7 and the whole g file
and i can still play neither form mmm i
also have a for him you form i would you
take with the Queen also what about
capturing isn't it's just good yeah why
not I can just capture this rook takes
Queen age 6 + f4 is a terrible weakness
for the night to come into y an idea for
not a force coming with them with real
force now we see that the loss of the G
porn is not really just a pawn it it's
giving up the whole Queen sir King side
structure with this being a typical way
to exploit okay just just go down why is
he putting the Queen actually though
okay should I play f6 can give this
check it's not okay come on need to be a
bit cook i am more than more than one
way here
I really don't see his night
participating in their check check and
what what is what is my play exactly i
can go Queen age 5 and maybe that f5
attacking the Queen yeah or maybe the
check of course on d3 the right moment
check and maybe night c5 trading off
this bishops one idea but I'm giving up
my my great night okay chattel I'm going
to do it I also have the check here i am
this is maybe just checking here and now
night f4 king age to Queen f1 s quite
strong check just the tech f2 it's no
really great way to cover that
yeah the end game or is this something
better now maybe just take this yeah b2f
twangs and I'm only very slightly behind
on the clock the night on f4 is just
fantastic right it covers d3 it limits
the king and fantastic piece on time
morning you just check just take it and
here 492 check
yeah that's really a lot of pawns you
don't want to give a man a pest porn
quickly and mine itís is quick enough
really and put it just on 1b8 check ok
now I'm i can just walk over with the
king in this is also
white resigns yeah this was a problem
right out of the opening I guess we go
all the way back and don't really think
that why does any compensation here I
only know d take c5 back back when I
played the French regularly this was at
least the the main continuation and
Knight f6 was played and after that I
think Knight f3 if i'm not i'm not
mistaken my dear three possibly not a
queen e to sorry Queenie to is the main
with Schneider three I can take only for
um yeah I don't know I mean 25 it just
looks a bit strange to to to allow that
because now you can only give away g2 or
you can opt for this which is a somewhat
weird version of them both the Queen b5
line what I'm talking about is there is
also this variation here c5 ed Queen
takes this variation and if you compare
this to the game if you would go here
now and I take let's put the bishop on
d3 and I just continue knight c6 Knight
f6 you're very often really want you
cook the Queen and then night be three
to get it back and here you're already
committed your Bishop to d3 yet here I
don't believe this is enough really I
really don't what I was briefly thinking
about is the vacuum move before which it
first looks ridiculous because of
Queenie five but it's not clear that
it's really that great I mean this is a
text and this f5 threaten but you can
probably play here as m5 Bishop b2 it's
a very convincing reply
maybe before is the way to go very messy
position maybe this is possible but here
i'm just a pawn up relief or for no for
no compensation whatsoever five years
even stronger than what i played
actually intending Bishop to g4 yeah
there's this is much stronger this is
much stronger I was just saw the
movement thought okay it's okay and I
didn't really look any further but the
e5 setup is just better yeah here black
is better but not winning and the with
e5 he was I was basically winning
immediately camp and around here check I
think this is beyond repair it's too
much night h5 is also strong here yeah
okay but jesus also can't quite quite
okay I guess okay thanks for watching